[Musique]
et on commence avec cette information le
château de Versailles a encore été
évacué aujourd'hui après une alerte à la
bombe et c'est déjà la troisième fois
que cela se produit en une semaine après
des évacuations samedi dernier et hier
le site des iines a dû fermer ses portes
et évacuer plus de 10000 visiteurs à la
mi-journée comme les deux précédentes
alertes le signalement de cette menace a
été réalisé via la plateforme
moncommissariat.fr faux salaire donc
encore une fois le château de Versailles
est resté fermé pendant près de 3h le
temps qu'une levée de doute soit
effectuée par les équipes de déminage il
a rouvert ses portes vers 15h ce matin
avait lieu une table ronde pour
améliorer l'attractivité économique de
la France c'était ce matin dans la salle
du conseil communautaire de C50 an
ibllin à traape cette réunion a été
menée par Charles Rodwell le député de
la première circonscription des iblines
depuis près de 6 mois le parlementaire
est chargé par la première-ministre
ellisabeth borne d'une mission auprès du
gouvernement le but à améliorer
l'attractivité des investissements
étrangers en France après avoir déjà
visité une trentaine de départements il
s'est donc rendu dans les iines ce matin
pour rencontrer des entreprises des élus
et des services de l'État afin de
recueillir leurs besoins et leurs
attentes sur cette thématique et nous
reviendrons sur ces échanges dans notre
édition de demain vous nous parlez à
présent d'un concept jamais vu en
Île-de-France la première pierre du
projet à premium a été posé hier au cœur
du quartier de l'hyercentre de 50 ans en
ibline ce site qui regroupe de bâtiments
doient accueillir le premier concept de
civing d'île-defance ce nouveau type
d'habitat est une forme moderne et
améliorée de la colocation les habitants
disposent d'espaces privés tout en
partageant certaines pièces comme le
salon le jardin ou une salle de sport
mais peuvent également travailler
directement sur place grâce notamment à
un espace de coworking on écoute les
propos recueillis par Clara de Frutos le
concept Babel c'est un concept de
bâtiment hybride qui met à la fois de
l'hébergement mais également du
coworking un restaurant une salle de
sport beaucoup d'événements un lieu
propice à la rencontre puisque nos
clients se rencontrent au sein d'espac
communs d'espaces collectifs très
nombreux du sport du restaurant mais
également plein d'espaces communs des
jardins partagés au sein même du même
bâtiment globalement c'est avant tout
une réponse à la à la difficulté de se
loger dans les grandes métropoles
notamment de la part des jeunes actifs
sur ce site qui est derrière moi où on
va construire un ensemble de 13000 m²r
composé enté de de de deux unités il y a
une opération de coliving colorking de
10000 m² pour Babel
community qui qui a regrouper 245
chambres
hôtelières destiné aux jeunes actifs et
un immeuble de 3000 m² de bureau
indépendant le prochain numéro de skych
mettra en lumière plus largement ce
projet premium math direction Mantel
jolie avec un événement qui va
intéresser les jeunes ivelinois en
recherche d'une formation le campus
départemental Paul sésane situé dans le
quartier du valfouret organise demain sa
Journée Portes ouverte c'est de 10h à
17h l'objectif répondre au manque de
qualification des jeunes bénéficiaires
du RSA au total 14 organismes de
formation seront présentés des métiers
de bouche du bâtiment au service à la
personne en passant par la sécurité ou
encore le numérique depuis son ouverture
l'année dernière le campus a déjà permis
la formation de 750 jeunes et enfin on
termine ces informations avec une expos
I qui va replonger certains d'entre nous
dans notre jeunesse tomtom et nana
est-ce que ça vous dit quelque chose
Mathilde bien sûr Michel j'avis quelques
tomes et bien la dessinatrice de la
célèbre bande dessinée Bernadette Despré
était hier soir au Musée du Jouet de
poissie présente pour l'inaauguration
d'une exposition dédiée à son œuvre elle
vous invite à découvrir dans les
moindres détails l'univers des deux
enfants terribles et les personnages qui
les entourent l'exposition est visible
dès demain et jusqu'au 7 janvier
prochain je pense que vous allez y faire
un petit tour
peut-être je vais voir merci beaucoup
Michel midoro pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
communiquer sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hhtag 7 news